vous savez que ce matin nous commençons
nos travaux à 9h par l'audition de
Madame Marie lordenis dont la nomination
en tant que présidente de la communation
de la Commission nationale de
l'information des libertés proposée par
le Président de la République il s'agit
là pour vous d'un second mandat puisque
c'est une reconduction davantage queune
nomination à proprement parler ce
pouvoir est conféré au président de la
République en application de l'article
13 de la Constitution soumis à l'AVE
préalable des commissions parlementaires
et la nomination ne peut avoir lieu que
si l'addition on des votes négatifs ne
dépasse pas les 3/5è des suffrages
exprimés par la commission vous serez
entendu ensuite par le Sénat la
commission des Lois du Sénat à 11h30 et
pour préserver la simultanéité des
travaux des deux commissions
parlementaires le dépouillement n'aura
lieu qu'après votre audition sénatoriale
avec l'annonce par la suite des
résultats dans nos deux chambres comme
on dispose l'article 29-1 du Règlement
de l'Assemblée la Commission a désigné
un rapporteur d'un groupe minor
minoritaire il s'agit de notre collègue
Philippe Pradal pour le groupe horison
que j'aiaccueillis à la tribune le
rapporteur vous a adressé un
questionnaire pour lequel vous avez
apporté des réponses écrites diffusé à
chacun de nos collègues ici présen ou
absent par ailleurs qui l'ont tous reçu
Monsieur le Rapporteur c'est vous qui
avez la parole pour
introduire merci monsieur le président
madame la Présidente mes chers collègues
madame la Présidente le président de la
République a proposé de vous reconduire
dans vos fonctions de président de la
Commission national Informatique et
Liberté en conséquence comme le
rappelait le président notre commission
vous reçoit afin de vous auditionner et
d'émettre un avis sur cette proposition
de nomination avant que le Sénat ne ne
fasse la même procédure j'aimerais
revenir rapidement sur votre parcours
afin de dire quelques mots de
l'institution dont vous assurz déjà la
présidence vous avez débuté votre
carrière au sein du Conseil d'État en
1992 vous avez ensuite exercé plusieurs
fonctions en cabinet ministériel avant
de rejoindre le Conseil supérieur de
l'audiovisuel en 2004 vous avez présidé
plusieurs groupes de travail dans celui
sur la protection de l'enfance enfin
avant de rejoindre l'acnil en février
2019 vous avez été successivement membre
du collège de l'Autorité de régulation
des communications électroniques et des
postes puis membre du comité de
réglement des différents et des
sanctions de la Commission de régulation
de l'énergie cette riche expérience vous
l'avez mise au service d'une institution
de régulation laaknil dont le rôle s'est
considérablement renforcé notamment
depuis l'entrée en vigueur du règlement
général sur la protection des données en
témoigne d'ailleurs l'augmentation des
effectifs que vous évoquez
dans votre réponse écrite de 200 ETP en
2019 passé à 288 au 1er janvier 2024
laacil exerce également et vous l'avez
bien présenté dans les réponses fournies
que vous nous avez transmis une
également une action de contrôle et de
sanction qui participe à responsabiliser
les entreprises privées notamment les
géants du numérique à leur rôle
fondamental en matière de protection des
données personnelles l'institution que
vous présidez est également en première
ligne pour garantir que l'application
des nouvelles technologies par les
pouvoirs publics et les entre reprise
protège les données personnelles des
individus et n'empièent pas sur leurs
libertés individuelles à l'échelle de la
commission des loin nous avons ainsi
beaucoup évoqué l'année dernière les
sorts des solutions d'intelligence
artificielle pouvant être utilisé en
matière de vidéoprotection notamment
pour autoriser l'expérimentation de la
vidéosurveillance algorithmique pendant
les Jeux Olympiques l'équilibre du
dispositif repose notamment sur le suivi
attentif conduit par votre instance lors
de la mise en œuvre de cette
expérimentation laacnil est ainsi
régulièrement sollicité pour donner un
avis sur les textes examinés à la
l'Assemblée nationale et au Sénat je
salue également nos collègues garido et
l tombe membres du collège de laakmil
nul doute que leur participation aux
travaux menés par laaknil contribue à
enrichir les nôtres avant de vous
laisser la parole je profite de mon
temps de parole pour vous remercier
d'ors et déjà pour les réponses écrites
que vous nous avez faites parvenir dès
lundi ainsi que pour celle que vous nous
apporterez dans le cadre de cette
audition madame la Présidente je vous
remercie merci monsieur le rapporteur
toujours à la fois bref concis et précis
madame la Présidente vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
députés je suis très honoré d'échanger
avec vous dans le cadre de cette
audition pour partager le bilan de 5
années d'action à laaknil et présenter
la façon dont j'aborderai ce second
mandat si l'occasion m'était donné d'y
poursuivre mon engagement à titre
liminaire je voudrais remercier les
membres du collège de laacnil et ses
agents qui au quotidien font preuve
d'une grande implication pour fournir un
service public de qualité le bilan que
je vais présenter est aussi
naturellement le leur je souhaite avant
tout rappeler que laacnil est une
autorité administrative indépendante
dont le champ d'intervention couvre tous
les secteur d'activité et c'est
probablement l'une des raisons qui
explique qu'elle est été auditionnée par
le Parlement plus de 120 fois depuis
2019 dont 62 fois par l'Assemblée
nationale je pense aussi utile de
rappeler que mon mandat a eu la
particularité de coïncider avec trois
événements majeurs inédits depuis la
création de l'institution le Pr premier
concerne l'entrée en vigueur effective
du règlement général sur la protection
des données le rgpd quelques mois avant
ma nomination dans un contexte de
numérisation accélérée de la société en
pratique cela s'est traduit par deux
changements importants une nouvelle
donne juridique pour les entreprises
nécessitant une action de pédagogie du
régulateur et une augmentation massive
des plaintes adressées à l'acnil puisque
leur nombre a doublé depuis 2018 pour
atteindre un pic de plus de 16000 en
2023 le deuxième événement c'est bien
sûr la crise sanitaire liée à la
covid-19 elle a posé des questions
vraiment nouvelles en matière
d'utilisation des données personnel et
nécessiter une mobilisation sans
précédent de l'acnil pour conseiller les
pouvoirs publics accompagner la
recherche médicale et contrôler le
respect des droits des personnes j'avais
eu l'occasion monsieur le Président de
vous présenter ce bilan fin 2022 et sur
ce seul sujet laaknil a rendu dans des
délais records 31 avis sur des projets
de texte répondu à 12 audition
parlementaire transmis puis publié CIN
rapports d'évaluation au Parlement
délivré 169 autorisations de recherche
en santé dont près des 2 tiers en moins
d'une semaine puis procéder à 53
contrôles enfin dans un registre très
différent le troisème fait notable de
ces 5 dernières années concerne
l'accroissement de l'exposition au
risques cyber principalement des petites
et moyennes entreprises des
collectivités territoriales et des
établissements hospitaliers les attaques
cyber peuvent souvent être évitées ou
atténué en appliquant des mesures de
sécurité simples c'est pourquoi l'acnil
accentue ses efforts d'accompagnement et
de contrôle chaque année parmi d'autres
actions elle mett ainsi à jour un guide
de la sécurité qui est largement
accessible au professionnel et
parallèlement le niveau de sécurisation
des données personnelles est évalué lors
de chaque
contrôle ces éléments de contexte étant
rappelés je souhaite expliquer comment
ces 5 dernières années l'acne a
poursuivi trois principaux
objectifs le premier concerne la
protection effective des données
personnelles des Français pour faire
face au nombre grandissant de cesines
laacnil a profondément modifié son
fonctionnement ceci aorté des fruits
puisque en 2022 et en 2023 nous avons
pour la première fois depuis plus de 10
ans traité plus de plaintes que nous
n'en avons reçu la plupart d'entre elles
se résout par des actions de
conciliation qui aboutissent à une mise
en conformité et seul une minorité
justifie des mesures répressives les
chiffres illustrent cette dynamique
chaque année donc comme j'ai rappelé
environ 16000 plaintes sont analysé 300
contrôles sont déclenchés et nous avons
triplé en 5 ans le nombre de mises en
demeure et de sanctions pour totaliser
en 2023 1668 mises en demeure et 42
sanctions donc dans la logique du rgpd
le montant des amendes prononcées s'est
élevé à plus d'un demi milliard
d'euros depuis 2019 594 millions 1ès
exactement avant cette date date la plus
grosse sanction de l'acnil se comptait
en centaines de milliers d'euros enfin
la possibilité de prononcer des
injonctions garantit la mise en
conformité le second objectif de laacnil
a été d'accompagner les administrations
et les entreprises pour leur apporter de
la sécurité juridique la protection de
la vie privée ne doit pas être vécu
comme un frein à l'innovation numérique
ni avoir pour effet de la ralentir sans
raisons objectives pour cela laacnil a
renforcé ses offres d'accompagnement et
a produit de nombreux instruments qui
relèvent de ce qu'on appelle le droit
souple cela c'est c'est pas la
commission des lois que je vais la
prendre d'ailleurs cela s'est traduit
depuis 2019 par l'adoption par notre
collège de près de 500 avis sur des
projets de texes législatives et
réglementaires le plus souvent rendus
public l'adoption ou la mise à jour
d'une cinquantaine d'outils de droit
souple des recommandations des
référentiels des guides le lancement
d'un cours en ligne suivi par plus de
170000 personnes et comportant
d'ailleurs un module très prisé euh
consacré au aux collectivités
territoriales nous recevons chaque année
1500 demandes de conseil d'entreprisees
et de fédération professionnelles et
nous avons un objectif de réponse sous 6
mois cette forme d'accompagnement est
utile mais cela n'est pas suffisant et
c'est pourquoi j'ai créé deux programmes
supplémentaires pour accompagner en
continu pendant 6 mois certains projets
innovants d'entreprise ou
d'administration l'un est un bacassable
c'est-à-dire une sélection de projets
correspondant à un thème annuel pour
lesquels nous allons aider un organisme
pas à pas à construire sa conformité au
rgpd chaque année une dizaine
d'organismes en bénéficie et l'édition
en cours est consacrée aux usages de
l'IA dans les services publics de
l'intelligence artificielle par ailleurs
un autre programme non thématique a
récemment été lancé il s'agit de
permettre aux entreprises enfin à des
entreprises qui ont le potentiel pour
devenir des acteurs majeurs de
l'innovation numérique et qui
candidatent auprès de nous d'être
conseillés par les équipes de l'acnil
pendant 6 mois sur leur bonne prise en
compte des enjeux de vie privée dans
leur système d'information c'est
vraiment de la régulation en amont
quelque sorte parallèlement j'ai voulu
initier une nouvelle méthode de
régulation qui puisse produire des
effets à grande échelle sur des sujets
qui concerne le quotidien numérique des
Français nous l'avons appliqué notamment
à notre action sur les traceurs
publicitaires ce qu'on appelle
communément les couquise et pour obtenir
la modification des interfaces de la
majorité des grands sites pour qu'il
soit aussi aisé dès le premier écran de
refuser les traceurs que de les accepter
nous avons procédé en 3 temps d'abord en
initiant une phase de dialogue avec les
organismes et les publics concernés pour
clarifier les règles c'est l'un des
rôles essentiels du régulateur puis s'en
est suivi une phase d'accompagnement
avant de lancer des campagnes de
vérification et de prononcer des mesures
correctrice lorsque c'était nécessaire
nous travaillons actuellement en
appliquant cette méthode qui a porté ses
fruits à mieux protéger les nombreuses
données sensibles exploitées par les
applications de nos téléphones portables
j'y reviendrai enfin le troè grand
objectif de laacneil a été de chercher
fort naturellement à mieux appréhender
les écosystèmes qu'elle régulent pour
apporter des réponses adaptées aux
nouveaux enjeu numérique dans ce but
j'ai pris l'initiative de créer trois
nouveaux services un service de
l'intelligence artificielle sujet sur
lequel je sais que votre commission
travaille activement il s'agit pour
l'acnil de renforcer son expertise sur
ce sur ces systèmes d'év er les risques
pour la vie privée et de préparer
l'entrée en application du futur
règlement européen sur l'intelligence
artificielle par ailleurs notre
laboratoire d'innovation numérique
analyse les tendances émergentes et mène
des expérimentations enfin une mission
économique est désormais chargée
d'étudier les modèles d'affaires liés à
l'utilisation des données personnelles
et de mesurer l'impact économique des
choix de
régulation ainsi durant ces 5 dernières
années l'acnil s'est continuellement
transformé pour répondre aux attentes de
ces publics je crois pouvoir dire
qu'elle représente une boussole
exigeante mais pragmatique pour protéger
la vie privée de nos concitoyens mais je
suis aussi consciente que dans un
environnement mouvant traversé par
l'émergence de nouvelles technologies et
notamment la révolution de
l'intelligence artificielle la seule
consolidation des actions entreprises ne
serait suffire à répondre aux enjeux
aussi je dédirai le second temps de mon
intervention à tracer les grandes lignes
de mon ambition pour un éventuel second
mandat si vous en décidez ainsi je
n'aurai pas le temps d'évoquer bien sûr
tous les sujets je serai bref sur les
Jeux Olympiques que monsieur le
rapporteur a a évoqué dans ses propos
liminaires en rappelant que l'acnil
continuera d'accompagner les pouvoirs
publics dans leurs souciis légitimes
d'assurer la sécurité de cet événement
hors norme mais c'est aussi le rôle de
laacnil dans le cadre de ce dialogue
déjà constructif de veiller à ce que la
protection de la vie privée soit bien
prise en compte comme par exemple dans
la mise en œuvre de la vidéosurveillance
algor rythmique et la collecte des
données personnelles pour l'accès à des
périmètres sécurisés au-delà de la
situation exceptionnel créé par les Jeux
Olympiques je retiendrai trois enjeux
essentiels pour l'acnil des enjeux qui
s'inscriront dans un cadre juridique
modifié par les nombres texte qui
constiue ce qu'on appelle le paquet
numérique européen mon premier défi
serait de concilier développement de
l'intelligence artificielle et
protection des données personnelles
j'emploie le mot défi à dessin parce que
le rgpd c'est minimisation des données
et l'IA demande des quantités
gigantesques de données le rgpd c'est le
tri entre données sensibles et non
sensibles et l'intelligence artificielle
exploite toutes les données le rgpd
c'est le droit d'accéder à ces données
personnelles de les faire modifier ou
effacer comment procéder parmi les 175
milliards de paramètres codés par chat
GPT et encore dans une versionin dans
une de ces anciennes versions et et
pourtant nous devons pouvoir nous aussi
en France et en Europe développer et
maîtriser ces nouvelles technologies ma
conviction c'est qu'il y a des réponses
à ces questions quand les moteurs de
recherche sont apparus le droit à la
protection des données personnelles a
été adapté pour trouver un équilibre
entre le bénéfice que cette innovation
apporte aux individus et la protection
des droits des personnes qui définit nos
sociétés
européennes nous n'avons pas banni les
moteurs de recherche évidemment mais
l'Europe a inventé le droit à l'oubl
pour en compenser les effets
indésirables l'acnil continue de jouer
un rôle majeur pour respecter cet
équilibre et c'est un défi du même ordre
quoi que plus complexe encore qui se
présente à nous avec l'intelligence
artificielle j'estime que c'est le rôle
de l'acnil que de veiller à ne pas
friner l'éventuel développement d'un
chat GPT français tout en protégeant ses
utilisateurs pour cela il faut indiquer
aux acteurs comment ils peuvent
développer ce type de modèle en se
conformant au rgpd en exploitant ces
marges d'interprétation car lia présente
des risques indubitablement et il faut
donc des garanties des précautions à
prendre en amont et des droits à
garantir en aval j'ai souhaité que
laacnil lance un plan intelligence
artificielle en mai dernier nous avons
déjà commencé à accompagn des
entreprises et des administrations et
d'ici l'été prochain nous aurons publié
un ensemble de recommandations
explicitant comment appliquer l'ensemble
des dispositions du rgpd en matière
d'intelligence artificielle les
premières sont déjà parus et ces travaux
se poursuivent de façon soutenue en
tenant compte naturellement du cadre
réglementaire européen le deuxième défi
que l'acnil doit relever c'est de
réguler davantage les applications sur
les téléphones portables beaucoup a été
fait depuis 20 ans par l'acnil pour
assaainir les traitements de données des
sites internet des politiques de de
confidentialité des interfaces pour les
cookies des formulaires en ligne ont été
contrôlés et améliorés mais alors que le
téléphone portable est est devenu le
premier vecteur d'accès au numérique les
applications mobiles sont bien plus
sensibles encore le site internet peut
utiliser vos données de
navigation le terminal mobile lui peut
donner accès à votre géolocalisation en
temps réel à un appareil photographique
et à un micro à vos photos et à vos
vidéos à l'ensemble de vos contacts avec
leurs coordonnées certaines réponses ont
été apportées par les acteurs l'acnil a
déjà effectué des contrôles et statués
sur des mais je crois qu'il faut en
faire plus en concertation avec les
acteurs nous devons avoir une approche
plus globale de la régulation de ce
secteur un large ensemble de
recommandations est en cours
d'élaboration et viennent d'être soumis
à consultation publique il s'agira d'un
pas doctrinal majeur pour la régulation
des applications mobiles je
souhaiteraiis le faire aboutir au cours
de l'année 2024 et en tenant compte d'un
temps d'adaptation pour le secteur
assurer ensuite le respect d'un haut
standard de protection de la vie privée
sur les applications mobiles
le trisème défi que l'acnil doit selon
moi se donner est tout à fait essentiel
car il concerne la protection des
enfants dans leurs interactions avec le
numérique ce sujet est sans doute le
plus urgent et le plus complexe la
représentation nationale s'en est
emparée dans le cadre de trois
propositions de loi et lors des débats
sur le projet de loi visant à sécuriser
et à réguler l'espace numérique les
effets indésirable du numérique sur les
enfants et les adolescents justifie une
très grande vigilance celle-ci passe par
un agement volontaris des mineurs et de
leurs parents dans leurs usages
numériques et par une protection
efficace des données en pratique pour
renforcer la protection des enfants en
ligne l'acnil doit d'abord continuer à
produire des contenus pédagogiques comme
elle l'a fait récemment pour les 8 10
ans et élargir les publics visés elle
doit ensuite accompagner les organismes
pour qu'ils prennent en compte les
spécificités du jeune public notamment
en déployant des mentions d'in formation
adapté à l'exercice de leur droits si
besoin en utilisant des icônes ou des
vidéos je pense au droit à l'effacement
de leur donné qui mérite toute notre
attention enfin l'acnil doit renforcer
ses contrôles en particulier sur le
respect de l'obligation d'exiger un
contrôle parental pour l'inscription des
mineurs de moins de 15 ans sur les
réseaux sociaux en conclusion et en
étant consciente de ne pas avoir eu le
temps d'évoquer de nombreux sujets
importants je veux souligner que l'acnil
veille à ce que le numérique soit VI au
service de chaque citoyen comme le
prévoit l'article 1er de la loi
Informatique et Liberté cette position
se reflète dans la promotion du rgpd
comme vecteur de confiance le respect de
la vie privée qu'il porte conditionne le
développement de l'innovation numérique
dans un cadre respectueux des libertés
et des droits fondamentaux des individus
ainsi mise en œuvre le rgpd et les
textes issus du nouveau paquet numérique
européens pourront constituer de
véritables leviers grâce auquels nous
nous efforcerons de garder la main
notamment vis-à-vis des plateformes
étrangères en renforçant notre
souveraineté numérique je vous remercie
de votre attention et je me tiens
maintenant à votre entière disposition
pour répondre à des questions merci
madame la Présidente alors avant de vous
donner à chacun la parole pour une durée
maximale de 2 minutes puisqu'il s'agit
d'une audition moi je voudrais vous dire
plusieurs choses d'abord vous remercier
pour le travail qu'on a conduit
notamment dans dans le cadre de la
période covid oou y compris jusque dans
l'évaluation des textes que nous avions
adopté qui malheureusement ont disparu
du code de la santé publique des
désormais nous avions pu établir toute
une série de préconisations qui ont à
chaque fois été prises en compte par le
par le législateur un travail législatif
qui par ailleurs a été enrichi par vos
travaux au moins à trois reprises pour
les textes régaliens d'abord sur la
question des attaques cyber dans la
lopmie et sur la prévention dont peuvent
bénéficier les établissements en
particulier les établissements publics
de l'État ensuite sur les logiciels
nouveau de de vidéos surveillance et
notamment dans la loi sur les les Jeux
Olympiques et puis enfin sur sur l'usage
le cadre de l'usage de toute la vidéos
surveillance particulièrement sur les
manifestations d'ampleur et je veux par
là parler des drones dont vous pourrez
peut-être nous dire aussi le cadre
d'application aujourd'hui comment vous
l'appréciez comment vous le jugez au vu
des des différents décrets qui ont été
adoptés sanctionné et puis rétablis dans
une forme qui soit plus acceptable après
des décisions du Conseil d'État et leur
application dans les manifestation
depuis le mois d'avril 2023 désormais eu
vous posez une question aussi en premier
lieu sur les annonces du président de la
République hier sur le contrôle des
écrans des enfants vous demandez si la
knil a été consultée sur ce sujet ce que
l'acnil préconise quant au temps d'usage
s'il s'agit d'un tempsusage qui est par
ailleurs limité au temps scolaire ou si
est également prévu dans le cadre
familial ou intime et dans ces
circonstances si l'ACN a préconisé un
type d'outil pour limiter le temps
d'écran ou pour accompagner les parents
notamment dans un guide d'utilisation si
tout cela relève du droit euh softlow
comme vous comme vous l'avez indiqué ou
si cela nécessite des transformations
législatives à venir pour laquelle
laacneil a d'ors et déjà été consulté
alors je vous remercie pour toutes vos
réponses par avance et je vous remercie
aussi pour cette présentation qui était
malgré ce que vous nous avez dit assez
complète en réalité madame l
Miller oui c'est bon merci monsieur le
Président euh au nom du groupe preneis
sens je vous remercie madame la
Présidente pour la clarté de votre
exposé et la précision de vos réponses
qui illustre le travail que vous avez
accompli à la présidence de l'acnil vous
aviez notamment l'enjeu immense de
mettre en œuvre le rgpd vous l'avez dit
qui a permis une protection des données
avec un véritable accompagnement des
entreprises et aussi des collectivités
territoriales vous aviez à la tête de
l'aknil la lourde tâche de communiquer
et de sensibiliser encore davantage les
Français sur l'enjeu de la protection
des données en effet nos concitoyens
avaient encore il y a pe pas si
longtemps le sentiment que la protection
des données personnelles était
accessoire aujourd'hui ils sont
majoritairement conscients que cette
protection est primordiale car elle
permet purement et simplement l'exercice
de nos libertés les plus fondamental les
données peuvent être des armes de
conquête pour les États comme pour les
entreprises alors oui la protection des
données personnelles est un enjeu
essentiel pour nos liberté publique et
laacneil occupe une place centrale dans
cette affaire il faut un ordre public
numérique déclarait le président de la
République dans son allocution du 24
juillet dernier c'est ce que vous
appelez vous de votre côté un
environnement numérique de confiance
c'est cette ambition comporter
gouvernement et la majorité avec la loi
de sécurisation et de régulation de
l'espace numérique et l'acnil prendra
toute sa part dans son application cette
loi charge en effet notamment laacnil de
contrôler de contrôler le respect des
règles qui encadrent le recours par les
fournisseurs de plateformes en ligne à
la méthode de la publicité ciblée
laacnil sera aussi engagé dans le cadre
de la mise en œuvre du filtre
anti-arnaque nous vous savons pleinement
mobiliser sur ces problématiques qui
affecte le quotidien numérique des
Français je voulais donc savoir si vous
pouviez nous dire un mot sur le bilan
que vous pouvez tirer de votre action
sur ces sujets et la méthode qui sera la
votre pour mettre en application les
dispositifs consacrés par la récente loi
pour clore mon propos je précise que
naturellement les députés du groupe
Renaissance souhaite vous renouveler
leur confiance je vous remercie alors
j'ai oublié de donner la parole à notre
rapporteur qui avait quelques questions
pour vous je je men excuse auprès de Lui
mer merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
aucun souci comme ça cela me permet de
de remercier l'appui reçu de l'ensemble
des administrateurs de commission des
lois en particulier madame ggou dans le
l'examen et la préparation de de cette
audience bjour et Madame la présidente
vous remercions à nouveau de la de la
clarté de votre propos et de la qualité
des des réponses écrites que vous nous
avez apporté deux questions à vous poser
euh a été évoqué à plusieurs reprises
dans vos interventions et dans les
réponses écrites le rôle de
d'accompagnement que l'acnil peut
exercer tant auprès des entreprises que
des collectivités je souhaitais savoir
comment vous envisageriez de mieux faire
connaître et comment développer ce rôle
d'accompagnement qui permet justement je
dirais à mon sens une amélioration de
des pratiques et d'aller vers ce que
vous décrivez une souveraineté numérique
qui soit respectueuse de la protection
des citoyens mais qui ne soit pas une
entrave au développement des nouvelles
technologies et et à la puissance de de
notre modèle sur ce sujet l'autre point
si vous avez évoqué un double mouvement
aussi concernant les cisines de l'acnil
à savoir que vous êtes beaucoup saisi
mais pas forcément de ce dont vous
devriez être saisi donc je voulais
peut-être vous amener à préciser votre
propos enfin votre propos écrit sur ce
point quel est à votre sens l'extension
éventuelle des champs sur lesquelacnil
devrait être obligatoirement saisie et
quels sont les points sur lesquels les
saisines de l'acnil vous paraissent
aujourd'hui superfitatoire voir inutille
merci
beaucoup merci monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur
gilet merci monsieur le président madame
la Présidente je voulais vous parler
d'un d'un sujet concret sur les fameuses
caméras lapis ces fameuses caméras à
lecture de plaque laacneil a épinglé
j'aime pas trop ce terme mais c'est
pourtant le cas a épinglé un certain
nombre de communes
qui utilisaient leur caméra lapis pour
verbaliser sur les forfaits post
stationnement pardon c'est interdit par
la législation et je ne le remets pas en
cause en revanche l'acneil a aussi
épinglé des communes qui utilisaient les
caméras lapis pour ceux dont elles sont
prévues c'est-à-dire pour pouvoir
enregistrer les plaques des voiture et
pouvoir servir
suréquisition des autorités compétentes
à des enquêtes ça pose ça pose un
problème il y a là finalement une
question aussi d'interprétation de la
loi alors je sais que laacnil évidemment
n'est pas en mesure de de son propre
chef de faire évoluer la loi en revanche
il y a une question d'interprétation la
loi dit notamment que ces traitements ne
sont licites que si euh et dans la
mesure où ils sont nécessaires à
l'exécution d'une mission effectuée pour
l'une des finalités énoncées aux
premières alinéa et cetera par une
autorité compét ente les services de
police et de gendarmerie nationale
peuvent mettre en place des dispositifs
fixes ou mobiles euh pour enregistrer
ses données en prenant notamment des
photographies des véhicules le problème
c'est que dans les faits dans les faits
ce sont les communes qui installent de
la vidéo surveillance et ce sont les
communes qui installent les caméras
lapis et on se retrouve là avec un
certain nombre de commune en France qui
se voit mis en demeure par l'acnil de
débrancher ces fameuses caméra
lapis la knil dit notamment que aucun
document ne prévoit cette collaboration
entre les services de l'État et les
communes or il y a quand même des
conventions de coordination entre les
police municipale et la police nationale
et les préfectures qui prévoi notamment
la mise en place des systèmes de de
vidéosurveillance aussi ma question est
la suivante et j'en termine excusez-moi
monsieur le Président pour ce léger
desbord mais la CNIL a-t-elle fait
concrètement des recommandations sur
l'évolution de la législation et en quoi
la CNIL accompagne-t-elle les
collectivités Monsieur Jean-François
coulom merci monsieur le président
madame la
Présidente les personnes concernées par
des traitements de données personnelles
disposent de droit leur permettant de
garder la maîtrise des informations les
concernants le responsable des fichiers
de données doit s'expliquer doit
expliquer aux personnes concernées la
procédure ou comment et à qui s'adresser
permettant de les exercer concrètement
le responsable du fichier dispose d'un
délai d'un mois pour répondre aux
demandes dans ce cadre et en vertu de
l'article 12-3 du rgpd il est exigé que
les banques facilitent aux emprunteurs
l'exercice des droits prévus par les
articles 15 à 22 du rgpd et notamment le
droit d'accès à leurs données
personnelles ainsi que le droit de
rectification le rgpd est protecteur
pour l'emprunteur puisqu'il exige que
les conditions économiques du prêt
soient aisément contrôlables par
l'exercice du droit d'accès lors d'un
litige concernant le recouvrement d'une
dette issue d'un prêt bancaire la banque
doit apporter la preuve de l'existence
du prêt accordé et dire à combien elle
estime le solde de la dette restendue
sans toutefois être obligé de prouver
l'exactitude de ce dernier inversement
c'est à l'emprunteur d'apporter la
preuve des paiements effectués et la
preuve du solde du prêt pourtant dans
certaines situations qui nous ont été
remontées les emprunteurs ne sont pas
informés de leur droit notamment de leur
droit d'accès à leurs données
personnelles les empêchons de prouver
l'état de leur soldes les qu peuvent
ainsi avancer un montant avec lequel les
emprunteurs ne sont pas d'accord sans
pour autant pouvoir prouver le chiffre
exact ceci entraîne des litiges longs et
coûteux pour les emprunteurs qui
débouchent sur des situations
inextricables où particuliers et
entreprises sont détenues captifs par
des organismes prêteur qui peuvent
opérer sur leur débiteur un chantage au
signalement à la Banque de France madame
la Présidente Denis partageant avec
votre prédécesseur Isabelle FAL pirrotin
une union conjugale avec un haut
fonctionnaire de banque que comptez-vous
faire pour que ces banques informment
systématiquement les emprunteurs de ce
droit dans le respect du rgpd afin
d'éviter les contentieux sans
possibilité de preuve contraire pour les
emprunteurs qu'il soit particulier ou
entreprise je vous
remercie merci alorssur n pas présent
madame
allez-y merci merci monsieur le
Président
merci présidente pour cet exposé moi
j'ai j'ai j'ai trois petites questions
la première c'est de deux questions et
une observation générale la première
question c'est sur les dopages sportifs
vous vous connaissez les tests
génétiques qui vont prévaloir pour
déterminer cette question des de pages
c'est vrai que ce sont des données
extrêmement intrusives qui doivent être
absolument protégées et j'aurais voulu
connaître le cadre d'application
permettant de satisfaire à cette
exigence de protection
ma deuxème question c'est sur les faux
avis sur Google sans doute n'est-ce pas
le cœur de votre métier mais je voulais
vous alerter quand même sur cette
situation parce que le temps de
réparation de ces faux avis n'est pas en
relation avec la le dynamisme de
l'entreprise qui le cas échéant fait
bien son travail et qui se trouve
pénalisé par des faux avis nous sommes
j'ai investigué auprès de Google et
c'est vrai que nous j'aimerais avoir
votre avis sur ce sujet et puis mon ma
troisème question qui est plus une
question d'ordre général c'est que bien
sûr merci pour votre travail sur le rgpd
euh merci aussi de de travailler à cette
protection des données mais moi j'ai un
peu quand même le sentiment que les
citoyens ont abandonné ce sujet ont
abandonné cette question et ont le
sentiment d'une impuissance très forte
face à cette obligation de protection
des données et abandonne peu à peu en
fait ce combat alors qu'il est tout à
fait essentiel et je me posaer la
question de savoir si l'acnil n'avait
pas un rôle d'information et de
communication très fort à ce sujet à à à
faire par à l'avenir je vous
remercie merci Monsieur Jérémy Yordanov
non vous étiz pas inscrit pas j' j'avais
pr group Monsieur David
ran merci monsieur le président madame
Denis bonjour bonjour à toutes et tous
après plusieurs années à la tête de
laaknil vous êtes la mieux placé pour
savoir que la révolution numérique
engendre des changements techniques
considérables on a donc vu émerger une
intelligence artificielle qui se
substitue de plus en plus à l'homme mais
contrairement à l'homme qui s'adapte à
son son environnement la machine elle se
soumet aux algorithmes statistiques or
en 2020 le Défenseur des droits sur la
base d'un travail mener avec vos équipes
publier un rapport visant à mettre en
lumière les risques considérables de
discrimination que peuvent faire peser
sur chacun de chacune d'entre nous
l'usage exponentiel des algorithmes 3
ans 3 ans plus tard nous nous nous
sommes encore un peu plus enfant dans
une société des algorithmes et de la
surveillance il faut en plus ajouter à
cela une actualité qui s'est focalisée
ces derniers mois autour d'un projet de
loi qui inst institutionnalise la
suspici à l'égard des personnes
immigrées qui sont chacun le sait
majoritairement des personnes racisées
vous êtes loin d'ignorer ceux carlaknil
participe à la lutte contre le racisme
en insistant notamment sur la nécessité
de vérifier si les algorithmes mis en
place remplissent bien leur fonction
sans créer de biais et particulièrement
dans les domaines d'accès à l'emploi à
un logement ou à l'éducation ex de
parcours sup est particulièrement
frappant malheureusement nous serons
tous d'accord pour dire que les billets
algorithmiques peuvent toujours que cela
soit volontaire ou non générer des
discriminations et on peut légitimement
craindre que l'essort de l'intelligence
artificielle contribue à allimenter ses
bis voire à renforcer certainement
discrimination raciale l'essort de l'IA
présentera donc un vrai défi avant tout
éthique dans les prochaines années
j'aurais donc aimé vous entendre sur la
manière dont laaknil a su s'approprier
cet enjeu au cours euh de votre premier
mandat et de quelle manière vous
envisagez de vous en emparer pour parer
les éventuelles dérives vers les formes
de racisme queil y a ou la
reconnaissance faciale pourrait générer
en la matière par
ailleurs nous avons été amenés ici même
à nous prononcer sur une proposition de
loi vérif prévoyant l'expérimentation
d'un service placé sous l'autorité du
Premier ministre qui aura en charge de
la réisation de test discrimination
individuelle ou
statistique si le ce texte venait entrer
en vigueur après son passage au Sénat
comment envisagez-vous l'articulation de
ce service à avec les prérogatives de la
je vous remercie merci Monsieur Paul
Molac merci monsieur le président madame
la Présidente donc l'institution que
vous présidez depuis 2019 joue un rôle
essentiel dans notre vie démocratique à
l'air du numérique en particulier aux
menaces et au risques toujours plus
élevés je crois que l'essentiel a été
dit dans votre avantpropos et les
réponses apportées au questionnaire de
notre rapporteur et nous vous sommes
grés
du travail que vous avez pu faire faire
pendant votre présidence à la tête de
cette institution et je vais donc
limiter me limiter à une question
concernant vos rapport avec l'état et
avec les
administrations on l'oublie parfois car
les actions de l'acnil font les gros
titres généralement lié au gfam Facebook
Microsoft et cetera l'acnil peut
également mener des actions contre
certains aspects par exemple de l'État
en manière de en matière de protection
des donné de respect des règlements
chacun est en droit d'attendre de l'État
un comportement exemplaire l'actualité
nous rappelle que la réalité est parfois
différente l'administration centrale
commet elle aussi des manquements le
rôle de l'acnil prend alors tout son
sentre mais je constate que le pouvoir
de sanction reste limité lorsque le
justiciable se trouve être l'État pour
appuyer mon propos je vais prendre un
exemple dont on a beaucoup parlé en
novembre 2023 laaknil a été saisie d'une
affaire concernant l'utilisation par
deux ministères Bery et le ministère de
la fonction publique d'une base de
données comportant les mails de plus de
2,3 millions d'agents publics pour
adresser un message une vidéo de 6
minutes ventant les mérite de la réforme
des retraites en plein débat à
l'Assemblée
nationale dans sa décision la
formulation rest la formation restreinte
du knil a souligné la gravité du
manquement à savoir le détournement
d'une base de données pour envoyer un
message politique étranger à sa fonction
laacil a relevé un nombre important de
personnes concernées elle a souligné les
hautes fonctions des responsables
publics concernés je rappelle que le
ministère de l'économie est aussi chargé
du numérique pour quel résultat un
simple rappel à l'ordre alors on peut
effectivement je vais faire cours alors
quel regard portez-vous sur la décision
prise dans ce dossier esttait suffisant
et pensez-vous que la palette de
sanction à la disposition de lail contre
les administrations gagnerait à être
renforcé merci Madame Emmanuel
mard
ci je vous rends la parole parce que
Monsieur MAAC vous l'avez subtilisé
c'est allez-y allez-y merci merci
monsieur le président madame la
Présidente les les conditions dans
lesqueles les services de la police les
gendarmerie nationale les douanes et les
militair peuvent procéder au moyen de
drone à la captation l'enregistrement et
la transmission d'images sont déterminé
dans le dans le code de sécurité
intérieure et la knil s'est prononcé à
deux reprises en janvier en juillet 2021
sur ces nouvelles position légale et
elle a rappelé un encadrement strict de
l'usage des drones compte tenu des
risques d'atteinte aux liberté publiqu
et à la vie privée des individus alors
en pratique les forces de l'ordre
peuvent être autorisées à utiliser des
caméras aéroportés donc les fameux
drones notamment pour la prévention
d'acte de terrorisme le secours aux
personnes la sécurité des rassemblements
de personnes sur la voie publique et
l'appui des personnels au sol en vue de
leur permettre de maintenir ou de
rétablir l'ordre public j'ai j'ai j'ai
une question parce que en fait on ne
mentionne pas explicitement la sécurité
des personnels justement qui assurent
ces missions ces missions de servicees
public et ces mission de de de de
sécurité et de et de garantie de
rétablissement de l'ordre public euh je
pense notamment aux pompiers et aux
policiers municipaux qui ne peuvent pas
utiliser les drones pour pouvoir
justement prévenir en tout cas
vérifier en amont de leur de leur
opération que qu'il ne s'agit pas d'un
guetapant qui leur est tendu par exemple
et donc je voulais savoir si vous envis
si vous envisagiez une évolution de
votre doctrine au sujet justement de
cette de cette utilisation des drones je
vous
remercie merci Monsieur Remy
rberotte euh monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Rapporteur madame la
Présidente simplement dire
qu'effectivement j'ai pu constater euh
en étant responsable du texte sur le
rgpd et ensuite en voyant la manière
dont les choses sétaient mises en place
combien vous savez à laacnil
démultiplier les moyens les missions
dans des conditions tout à fait
remarquables moi qu'on puisse dire c'est
que vous ne restez pas les deux pieds
dans le même sabot comme on dit chez moi
voilà les choses avance et les les
choses se projettent euh simplement par
rapport à à aux nouveaux enjeux que vous
avez définis avec le laboratoire que que
vous menez notamment sur l'intelligence
artificielle la question de la
multiplication des applications la
question de l'accès au mineurs et de
l'effacement des données comment vous
voyez l'évolution des moyens de l'acnil
parce que je trouve que vous faites
énormément avec des moyens limités même
si même si ils ont été renforcés
heureusement ces dernières années face
aux nouvelles missions que vous devez
porter mais comment voyez-vous les
choses comparer notamment à à d'autres
institutions comparables dans d'autres
pays européens où bien souvent il y a
beaucoup plus de moyens et humain et
technique ou matériel pour faire face
aux enjeux voilà c'est un peu cette
prospective sur les moyens accompagnant
la vision que vous avez par rapport aux
missions et aux évolutions que que vous
portez monsieur Jordan Guiton oui merci
monsieur le président madame la
Présidente donc vous êtes présidente de
la commission nationale d'informatique
et des libertés depuis 2019 les missions
de laacnil sont essentielles afin de
protéger les données personnelles des
Français et d'année en année on le voit
chaque débat sur chaque texte à
l'Assemblée ce sujet est devenu majeur
et un enjeu de souveraineté pour notre
pays tout d'abord vous en avez parlé
dans vos propos introductifs les Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques qui se
dérouleront cette année seront en proid
à de nombreuses cyberattaques je
rappelle que lors des gios de Londres il
y a eu plus de 200 millions de
cyberattaques qui ont lieu notamment
lors de la cérémonie d'ouverture et à
Tokyo en 2021 il y en a eu 450 millions
le niveau de menace va être multiplié
par 10 estime le comité d'organisation
des Jeux Olympiques donc donc madame la
Présidente pouvez-vous nous donner votre
avis concret sur la préparation de ces
Jeux Olympiques peut-être en développant
et la défense de notre pays face à ses
futures menaces ensuite nous avons voté
pour ce texte sur le texte des Jeux
Olympiques qui est passé à l'Assemblée
les fameuses caméras algorithmiques que
vous avez aussi cité dans vos propos
introductifs pouvez-vous nous dire dans
quelle mesure et par quelle action
concrète contrôlerez-vous les
prestataires de ces services qui
pourront avoir accès notamment à
certaines données et que pensez-vous
dans le temps de cette expérimentation
des caméras qui ira jusqu'au 31 mars
2025 soit 6 mois après les Jeux
Olympiques enfin Madame la Présidente
une dernière question qui concerne
l'intelligence artificielle à des fins
politiques nous l'avons vu plusieurs
personnalités ont ont évidemment fait
comme chaque année leur vœux sur
Internet et le porte-parole de
Renaissance a utilisé l'intelligence
artificielle pour détourner la vidéo de
vœux de de Marine Le Pen donc quelles
seront les actions concrète de l'acnil
afin d'enjoindre les plateformes
numériques à supprimer rapidement ces
falsifications et ainsi protéger la
démocratie de détournement des données
il me semble que la lutte contre
lesffectus était un objectif de ce
gouvernement qui malheureusement
l'utilise parfois à des fins politiqu
monsieur av
souignac merci Monsieur le le président
madame la Présidente je voulais vous
vous interroger sur ce qui a fait débat
je crois c'était au mois de décembre
dernier s'agissant de de l'algorithme
utilisé par les caisses d'allocation
familiales et et les pratiques qui en nt
été faites pour orienter la la politique
et et le contrôle de ces locataire euh
les critères qui ont été enfin qui sont
utilisés dans ces algorithmes tels que
les les revenus le chômage des les
allocations perçues par ailleurs au
titre du RSA la situation géographique
le handicap le statut de mère
célibataire semble tout à fait
discriminatoire et ciblerait de manière
disproportionnée donc les les
populations les plus vulnérables les
conséquences de cet algorithme sont
assez alarmantes puisqu'elle générerait
un score de suspicion qui pourrait dans
certains cas privé les allocataires de
leur de leur droit la presse a également
fait état de discrimination de de genre
opéré par des algorithme s'agissant
notamment de parcours sup et par
conséquent ces pratiques soulèvent bien
entendu des questions absolument
fondamentales sur l'éthique sur l'équité
de de l'utilisation des algorithmes dans
le secteur public alors je voudrais
savoir en tant que actuel et futur
probablement président de l'acnil savoir
si euh vous avez euh agi en la matière
quel action avez-vous entrepris ou
quelles actions envisagez-vous
d'entreprendre pour garantir que
l'utilisation des algorithmes dans le
secteur public respecte bien les
principes éthiques fondamentaux de notre
société je vous
remercie madame Sandra rol merci
monsieur le Président toutes mes excuses
ce matin je suis un ddat et pas ici même
si je tenais à suivre quand même cette
audition vous avez abordé madame la
encore président
ente certains aspects sur lesquels tout
à l'heure dans votre introduction dans
sur lesquels j'aimerais avoir un petit
peu plus de précision vous le savez
plusieurs collègues l'ont dit la
question de l'évolution des définitions
de ce qui est du domaine de l'acceptable
sur les
données sensibles particulièrement est
une question qui agite beaucoup cette
commission on a parlé de l'intelligence
dit artifici enfin de de l'intelligence
artificielle de la vidéo surveillance
algorithmique des divers systèmes mis en
place sur lesquels laacnil a été
sollicité vous savez que depuis quelques
temps les tribunaux administratifs sont
largement sollicités sur les logiciels
utilisés la façon dont ils sont utilisés
et la qualification des données qu'ils
ont à répertorié je pense notamment au
jugement du tribunal administratif de C
qui a été partiellement censuré par le
Conseil d'État mais qui en Store en
début de doctrine et pourtant pourtant
le législateur continue à être fasciné
par l'innovation ce qui est très bien
l'innovation ça permet d'avancer mais
l'innovation elle est innovante dans la
mesure où on prend conscience des
conséquences qu'il y a hors en matière
de données sensibles euh Données à
Caractère biométrique ou données
biométriques données à caractère
personnel ou données personnelles et
bien il y a là euh toute une législation
dans laquelle l'acnil est souvent à
peine sollicité consulter des avis qui
ne sont pas euh toujours suivis en tout
cas par l'État et dans les les plus
hautes juridictions sont sans cesse
amené à trancher vous voyez bien qu'il y
a un petit souci dedans et que nous en
tant que législateur avons besoin d'être
éclairé par des spécialistes j'ai
entendu que vous renforciez la
commission dédiée à lia que vous
renforciez toutes ces questions là donc
j'aimerais savoir quel est votre plan
pour la suite du mandat sur ces
questions qui ne cesseront de
s'accentuer merci Monsieur Stéphane
rambau merci Monsieur merci monsieur le
président madame l'intelligence
artificielle générative l'IAG est devenu
depuis quelques mois vous le savez un
sujet à la mode largement vulgarisé par
le robot conversationnel de la société
américaine open chat GPT objet de
curiosité ce chatbot permet de créer
très rapidement des contenus originaux
visuels sonores ou écrits par le biais
d'une interface simple accessible à tous
la puissance créatrice de cet outil
numérique fascine le plus grand nombre
ce qui est explique largement son succès
auprès du grand public mais l'IAG
soulève aussi beaucoup de questions en
particulier sur la protection des
données personnelles et l'utilisation
des contenus générés et suscite donc de
l'inquiétude en matière de droit
d'auteur ou de manipulation
d'information de ce fait l'Union
européenne a réussi à finaliser
dernièrement un accord sur l'encadrement
de l'intelligence artificielle et plus
particulièrement sur la régulation des
IA génératives et l'intégration
d'exception à l'usage de l'IA dans le
domaine de la sécurité en parallèle de
la création d'une réglementation
européenne la France peut et surtout
doit pouvoir contribuer aussi par son
droit interne au développement d'une IAG
respectueuse et données personnelles de
la protection des citoyens des liberté
fondamentale les mécanismes de
régulation et de surveillance à mettre
en place qu'ils soi européens ou
nationaux nécessiteront la saisine d'une
autorité indépendante je pense que
laacnil est toute désignée pour remplir
ce rôle puisqu'elle en a déjà
l'expertise et l'expérience en matière
de protection des données personnelles
bien que mon avis sera favorable à votre
reconduction j'ai une question simple
l'acnil entend-elle assurer cette
fonction de protection des données
personnelles lié au développement des
technologies d'intelligence artificielle
et aussi être le gendarme de l'
générative Monsieur Didier
Paris
merci j'ai la parole merci monsieur le
président madame la Présidente euh bien
sûr il y a ça vient d'être largement
évoqué des questions d'intelligence
artificielle mais on a aussi à
l'approche des Jeux Olympiques la la
situation va être encore renforcé
problématique de gestion des fichiers
des fichiers de police et des fichiers
de renseignement pour avoir mené une une
mission d'études sur cette question il y
a quelques années déjà j'avais pu voir à
quel point nous avions de nombreux
fichiers que les contrôles d'un certain
nombre d'entre eux étaient on va dire
relatifs difficile en tout cas
l'exercice des droits sur les fichiers
par les citoyens encore une fois de
renseignement ou de police mérite d'être
encore améliorer et en et d'être d'être
certain l'acnil joue un rôle important
puisqu'on peut s'adresser soit au à
l'administrateur du fichier soit à
l'acnil en fonction de la nature
elle-même des fichiers est-ce que vous
pourriez madame la présente nous dire
comment ce contrôle actuel s'exerce
comment il a pu évoluer au fil des
années est-ce que vous êtes fréquemment
saisis je pense en partiul au Tage au
traitement des antécédces judiciaires où
de très nombreuses personnes y figurent
y compris parce qu'ils ont été entendu
en tant que témoins ou ou dans des
conditions qui ne mettaient pas en cause
leur propre responsabilité et le
nettoyage parmtez-moi l'expression du
Tage est parfois relatif est-ce que vous
pouvez nous nous refaire un point de
situation sur ces question
qui sont des questions de de sécurité
publique et y compris à l'approche des
Jeux Olympiques où elles seront sans
doute encore plus importante
qu'antérieurement merci Madame il reste
deux intervenants et ensuite vous
répondrez madame la présidente madame
marieance
lorau merci monsieur le président madame
la Présidente le 29 novembre dernier le
préfet de police de Paris annoncé les
dispositif qu'il souhaitait mettre en
place dans le cadre des Jeux Olympiques
à Paris et en île-de-fance à cette
occasion il a que la liberté de
circulation serait conditionnée à la
validation d'un QR code dans certaines
zones la généralisation du QR code est
effectivement particulièrement
inentatoire à la liberté de circulation
garantie aux articles 2 et 4 de la
Déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen je m'inquiète de la pérennité
d'une mesure initialement mise en place
à l'occasion de la crise sanitaire une
mesure dans laaknil avait d'ailleurs
indiqué dans son avis du 12 mai 2021 la
nécessité de s'assurer du caractère
temporaire dans ce rapport laacnil avait
souligné que le dispositif devrait
intégrer un certain nombre de garanties
afin de limiter autant que possible la
divulgation et la conservation
d'informations privées or les QR codes
ne sont pas exemple de faillees en
matière de cybersécurité il pourrait
faire l'objet d' d'amsonnage et mettre
en et mettre en en danger les données
personnel des riverins pardon les
personnes scannant ces dispositifs
pourrai aussi faire l'objet de logiciel
malveillant des QR Codes entraînant vers
une mauvaise destination entraînant la
fragilisation du dispositif madame la
Présidente l'acnil entend-elle cause ner
la pérennité d'un dispositif qu'elle ne
souhaitait pas voir prolongé à
l'occasion de la crise sanitaire quelle
garantie de sécurité laacnil entend
donner aux Français pour protéger leur
données à l'occasion des Jeux Olympiques
je vous
remercie merci et enfin Monsieur
Philippe goselin merci monsieur le
Président quelques mots madame la
Présidente mais on voit bien que le
suspense n'est pas trop intense sur les
votes qui pourraient être fait tout à
l'heure oui il y a eu beaucoup de choses
de dites sur l'IA sur les les Jos sur la
cybersécurité et je ne vais pas formuler
les questions mais elles vont dans le
dans le même sens en revanche il y en
avait deux et qui une qui qui rejoint ce
qui a été dit par y ribbrot tout à
l'heure et quelques autres et par Didier
Paris quel regard vous portez sur les
fichiers la gestion des fichiers bon ce
sont des sujets qui régulièrement
reviennent ici qui régulièrement
reviennent évidemment à la à l'acnil
aussi et queles sont pour vous les
perspectives idéal financière
c'est-à-dire les
capacités financières de de l'acnil et
en terme de recrutement ça a été dit
aussi tout à l'heure laacnil fait
finalement beaucoup avec des moyens
plutôt mesuré et on peut s'en s'en
réjouir mais face à de nouvelles menaces
de nouvelles fonctions est-ce que vous
estimez ces besoins suffisants et sinon
quelle serait la la hauteur
souhaitable bien je pense que aucune
question n échappé à la sagacité des
législateurs et donc madame la
Présidente vous pouvez désormais y
répondre merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président vous vous me laissez combien
de temps c'est juste pour savoir pour
adapter mon vous vous n'avez pas de
temps imparti alors sauf si vous faites
une demi-heure au quel cas je seraai
obligé de vous demander de
conclure vous avez la liberté de de
temps très bien merci beaucoup et je
suis euh en tout cas très sensible au
fait que autant de députés et membres de
la Commission a posé des questions très
variés ce qui traduit l'intérêt que vous
portez au sujets sur lesquels travaille
l'acnil et je vous en remercie alors il
y a eu d'abord quelques questions
euh
sur les drone
euh notamment de Madame Ménard mais
aussi euh une autre question euh sur le
sujet euh donc sur les drones l'acnil a
attiré d'abord l'acnil a eu un rôle très
actif hein sur les drones et et
notamment sur le fait qu'elle a vu voler
des drones pendant le confinement euh
elle s'est interrogé sur la base légale
qui permettait de faire voler ces drones
euh qui volait qui pour détecter des
personnes qui s'affranchissaient des
règles de confinement encore une fois il
y a un équilibre à trouver bien naturel
entre la sécurité publique et la
protection de la vie privée mais encore
faut-il et dans cette salle je crois que
je peux le dire en étant comprise qu'il
ait un cadre légal et des garanties qui
soient apporté donc après d'ailleurs une
décision du Conseil d'État qui a
interdit l'usage des drones pour cette
raison-là d'absence de base légale sur
une manifestation particulière j'ai
saisi la formation restreinte de l'acnil
c'est-à-dire la commission des sanctions
de l'acnil qui a elle-même quelques mois
plus tard prononcé une injonction
générale euh interdisant aux forces de
l'ordre d'utiliser des drones tant qu'il
tant que un cadre légal ne soit pas
établi et vous êtes bien placé pour
savoir que après il y a eu une loi une
décision du Conseil constitutionnel et
cetera et maintenant il y a euh des
garanties qui ont été apportées par le
législateur il faut un arrêté
préfectoral qui est lui-même susceptible
de recours devant le juge administratif
il y a un quota sur l'usage des drones
par département
euh il faut informer autant que possible
avec cette technologie sur laquelle il
est difficile d'informer en tout cas de
l'utilisation des drones comme ça a été
dit par l'un d'entre vous qui a listé
les les finalités ce sont que pour des
finalités qui sont déterminées et et
j'en profite pour dire que ce n'est pas
à laacnil de préciser s'il faut que ce
soit les pompiers ou les policiers
municipaux qui peuvent utiliser des
drones c'est vraiment le rôle du
législateur que de le faire euh et en
revanche laacnil elle s'assure que les
personnes qui ont accès à ces images
sont limité que toutes les garanties qui
ont été prévues par la loi euh ont été
ou sont euh respectter parce que les
drones c'est une nature de surveillance
qui est potentiellement très intrusive
je n pas du tout son intérêt en terme de
sécurité potentielle mais très intrusive
parce qu'elle peut être
imperceptible alors qu'il s'agit puisque
c'est dans l'espace
public d'un lieu d'exercice des libertés
publiques de
manifestation syndical de culte et
cetera et par exemple lanil vérifie très
concrètement que il a les intérieurs des
immeuble ne soit pas filmé enfin tout
tout toutes les garanties donc en tout
cas l'acnil a vraiment agi je je crois
pour
encadrer cette technologie de
surveillance en ce qui concerne monsieur
le Président vous m'avez interrogé sur
le contrôle des écrans suite à l'annonce
du président de la République hier
l'acnil en tout cas euh je pense que
c'est une question qui est aussi du
ressort de l'arcom hein très largement
en ce qui concerne l'acnil je pense que
sur cette problématique nous faisons
deux choses d'abord nous faisons quand
même beaucoup de pédagogie en matière
d'éducation au numérique et pour moi
l'éducation au numérique ça concerne à
la fois les parents et les enfants en
quelque sorte mais je le dis pas du tout
d'une façon arrogante prétentieux je
crois qu'on a tous à apprendre en la
matière et on a beaucoup d'actions on
fédre un collectif s'appelle educnum
éducation numérique sur ces sujets avec
beaucoup de parties prenantes on a un
partenariat avec avec l'Éducation
nationale on fait beaucoup de ressources
là on a fait des ressources pour les 8
10 ans par exemple qui sont extrêmement
concrètes des vidéos des jeux de cartes
qui peuvent attirer l'attention sur à la
fois le fait que le numérique c'est une
opportunité mais il y a aussi des
risques donc c'est toutes ces actions
d'éducation au numérique que l'on va
prolonger là on va faire un manga pour
les collégiens par exemple euh mais
surtout je crois qu'en l'espèce de de de
avec des effets probablement plus
puissants moi j'attends beaucoup
personnellement du contrôle parental
laacnil a rendu un avis récemment sur un
décret sur le contrôle parental qui doit
exister dorénavant
sur tous les supports numériques enfin
tous les euh instruments numériques les
téléphones les ordinateur les tablettes
les consoles de jeu euh pour souligner
dans son avis que nous pouvions en tout
cas de notre point de vue aller plus
loin que ce qui était prévu dans le
décret en terme de contrôle parental il
faut peut-être avoir des contrôle
parental vraiment activés par défaut
enfin je sais que ce décret d'ailleurs
est soumis à un contentieux actuellement
et nous nous sommes rapprochés nous
continuons à nous rapprocher de la NFR
d'ailleurs qui a de l' sance nationale
des fréquences qui à la charge de mettre
en œuvre concrètement en tout cas les
spécificités techniques de ce contrôle
parental
euh madame lmiller a attiré mon
attention sur la publicité euh ciblée et
le blocage des sites internet dans la
loi serine
euh qui n'est pas encore en vigueur mais
pour laquelle je crois qu'une commission
mixte paritaire est prévue euh le mois
prochain euh bah en terme de publicité
c'est une des compétences que nous
partageons avec l'arcom notamment
l'acnil depuis euh euh au moins une
dizaine d'années est très active sur ce
sujet euh que ce soit en matière de
prospection commerciale euh que ce soit
dans notre régulation des cookies par
exemple dont j'ai parlé des traceurs euh
que ce soit sur le travail qu'elle mène
sur ce qu'on appelle les dat brokers
c'est-à-dire les courtiers en données
c'est vrai que euh finalement l'intérêt
du contrôle de l'acnil au-delà de euh
fixer des bonnes pratiques pour les
professionnels de ce secteur et et
laacil a eu la
main en tout cas n'a pas hésité à mettre
des sanctions tout à fait significative
he en ce qui concerne le profilage
publicitaire et et et finalement les
applications mobiles c'est aussi la même
problématique
euh donc
euh nous continuerons sur cette lancée
en ce qui concerne le filtre
anti-arnaque dans dans dans la loi Seren
donc il s'agit de
bloquer des sites qui notamment pour des
raisons cyber ENF constituerait comme
son nom l'indique des enfin aurait des
porterait des intentions malveillantes à
l'égard de de leurs utilisateurs et le
projet de loi préconise prévoit en tout
cas qu'il y ait un membre de l'acnil
probablement un membre de son collège
une personnalité qualifiée qui puisse
être enfin le recours qu'on puisse lui
adresser des recours de la part des
sites et il y en a de nombreux hein qui
sont potentiellement concernés euh pour
concilier la liberté d'expression et
euh et la
protection de la vie privée
euh il faut juste bien veiller donc nous
on est tout à fait heureux laacnil est
tout à fait heureuse d'endosser ce rôle
il faut quand même veiller au nombre de
cesines qui pourrait y avoir l'acnil
considère que ça serait une très bonne
pratique en tout cas qu'il ait d'abord
un avertissement avant le blocage du
site ne serit-ce que pour le respect de
la liberté d'expression qui avertit
l'utilisateur du site que il est
potentiellement sur un site malveillant
c'était notre préconisation et et puis
s'il y a un blocage du site nous
traiterons ces recours en espérant et ça
rejoint une question de Monsieur reberot
sur les moyens sur lesquel je reviendrai
euh mais que je peux traiter aussi
maintenant que
euh
euh que les moyens de l'acnil que nous
évaluons nous évaluons en tout cas cette
mission éventuellement à 5 ou 10 emplois
à temps plein supplémentaires et et j'en
profite pour répondre à à Monsieur
reberot sur les moyens c'est vrai que
les pouvoirs publics ont accompagné
depuis quelques années la croissance et
le renforcement des démissions de de
l'acnil et ça a été extrêmement utile
puisque quand je suis arrivé à laacnil
il y avait de 215 agents et aujourd'hui
il y en a 288 par exemple mais monsieur
reberot faisait référence à à des
homologues les Anglais par exemple ont
plus de 1000 agents pour des
prérogatives qui sont sensiblement les
mêmes les Allemands même si c'est un
système fédéral et donc les comparaisons
peuvent être faussées également et on
voit bien que la tendance de la
numérisation de la société va euh vers
une un un accroissement en tout cas
desmissions qui sont confiés à l'acnil
ça se traduit par l'augmentation des
plaintes par les sollicitations qu'on
reçoit des des professionnels et et j'en
profite pour répondre à une partie de la
question de Philippe Gosselin qui
connaît très bien l'acnil pour dire que
effectivement nous nous avons tout en
ayant le sentiment d'être bien
accompagné et bien compris nous avons
besoin de de moyens supplémentaires ne
serait-ce que pour pouvoir recruter dans
un secteur de plus en plus concurrentiel
sur la protection de la vie privée des
ingé ur des informaticiens des juristes
de de qualité et aussi moyen financier
simplement pour pouvoir mener à bien nos
missions renforcer nos systèmes
d'information par exemple et faire de la
pédagogie puisque
comme l'a dit
très de façon tout à fait intéressante
l'une d'entre
vous est-ce qu'il y a c'était
madametermerer la question de la
sensibilisation des cito yen euh alors
je je partage et je ne partage pas votre
point de vue en quelque
sorte j'ai bien conscience
que quelqu'un qui se retrouve devant un
portable ou un ordinateur favorise
l'utilité immédiate de de la démarche
qu'il entreprend sans nécessairement de
se soucier de ces données bon tout ce
qu'on a essayé de faire quand même
toutes nos actions visent à plus de
transparence redonner du contrôle aux
individus sur leur données par exemple
notre régulation sur les cookies avant
qu'on l'entreprenne je je dis pas que
c'est que l'action de l'acnil qui
explique ce résultat mais avant qu'on
l'entreprenne il y avait moins d'un
Français sur deux qui savait ce qui
était un traceur publicitaire donc il
avait conscience qu'il était tracé en
allant sur Internet après notre
régulation au bout de 2 3 ans il y a 95
% des Français qui sont conscients de ça
alors après ils prennent le temps de
cliquer sur le petit continuer sans
accepter en haut à droite qui n'existait
pas avant ou pas mais voilà des actions
concrètes quand même qui concernent le
quotidien numérique des français quand
on a un doublement des
plaintes par rapport à y 5 ans ça prouve
quand même qu' il y a aussi une
sensibilisation mais je pense
fondamentalement mais je pense
fondamentalement que les personnes c'est
quand il leur arrive quelque chose par
rapport à leur données qu'ell prennent
conscience des enjeux et ça peut être
des attaques cyber malheureusement il y
en aura de plus en plus
euh et c'est tout le rôle de l'acnil en
tout cas de faire de la pédagogie sur
ces sujet monsieur le
rapporteur m'a posé deux questions sur
le le rôle de l'accompagnement de
l'acnil comment mieux faire encore je je
pense
que il faut absolument ce que nous
faisons déjà mais renforcer encore cela
nous adosser à des têtes de réseau à des
fédérations professionnelles à des euh
au partenariat que nous avons noué par
exemple avec l'association des MRES de
franceassociation des départements de
franceassociation des régions de France
compte tenu de l'enjeu de la protection
des données dans les Collectiv ité
territoriale j'ai signé au salon des
mèes un partenariat avec les chambres de
commerce et d'industrie qui ont une
action et qui peuvent elles quadriller
le terrain ce que l'acnil ne peut pas
faire parce que l'acnil n'a pas
justement de
euh de service déconcentrés même si nous
nous projetons maintenant beaucoup plus
en région nous avons fait cinq grands
événements en région l'année dernière ce
qui a été une façon je pense de diffuser
également euh les bonnes pratiques et
pour laacil de s'enrichir des de mieux
appréhender les difficultés que
rencontrent les responsables de de
traitement de données donc ça nous
allons également prolonger euh cette
action
euh alors sur les saisines de l'acnil
qui était une des questions du
questionnaire si j'ose dire euh c'est
vrai que laacnil est heureuse d'être
beaucoup saisie sur des projets de loi
et des projets de décret et nous rendons
plus d'une centaine d'avis par an hein
c'est quand même beaucoup le collège de
laaknil sur des projets de loi et et et
de décrets euh comme le rgpd c'est un
principe de responsabilisation on peut
se dire que parfois certains décrets ne
mériteraient pas nécessairement qu'il y
ait 18 personnes membres du collège de
laaknil autour de la table euh pour les
étudi d'autres sont tout à fait
importants euh sachant que le principe
de de responsabilisation ça veut dire
que l'acnil peut aller contrôler vous
avez eu beaucoup de questions qui ont
été posées sur les les fichiers
notamment et et laaknil le fait
abondamment en revanche c'est vrai que
parfois on est étonné parce que la loi
ou le projet de loi ne comporte pas les
caractéristiques essentielles du
traitement de ne pas pouvoir donner
d'avis par exemple euh sur un texte qui
concernait le ministère de la Justice et
qui prévoyait l'activation des
téléphones portable à l'insu des
personnes y compris pour les
conversations enfin quelque chose
d'extrêmement euh intrusif euh donc il
faut effectivement qu'on travaille
euh pour pour voir si euh à l'occasion
d'une modification de texte ou pas il y
a euh euh quelque chose à à améliorer
sur ce sujet merci en tout cas euh
d'avoir posé cette question alors
Monsieur gilet a posé une question très
concrète sur les lapis
euh en disant que laacneil avait épinglé
euh des communes les lapis hein je je me
permets de vous le rappeler vous le
savez parfaitement ce sont les la les
dispositifs algorithmiques hein qui
permettent la lecture automatisée de
plaques d'immatriculation d'où la
euh que les communes mettent en œuvre
pour s'assurer du paiement euh du
stationnement euh alors quand vous dites
monsieur gilet qu'on a épinglé euh on
aurait pu beaucoup plus épingler parce
que je me suis contenté à ce stade de
mettre une mise en demeure une mise en
demeure ça n'est pas une sanction c'est
on écrit et et d'ailleurs j'ai j'ai pas
j'ai sur des mise en demeur qui n'ont
même pas été publ j'ai écrit
effectivement à 38 communes euh pour
leur dire que elle pouvait tout tout à
fait utiliser leur système pour
contrôler le paiement du stationnement
mais qu'ell ne pouvait pas
l'utiliser
pour vérifier pour constater des
infractions sachant qu'effectivement
beaucoup d'entre elles non mais je me
permet juste de de terminer
pardon d'accord parce que si si je peux
me permettre effectivement le le droit
est assez simple même si c'est un sujet
complexe c'està-dire oui les communes
peuvent utiliser des traitements
algorithmiques pour contrôler que les
euh les détenteurs de voiture ont bien
payé leur stationnement mais elles ne
peuvent pas elles-mêmes regarder en fait
les images qui ont été enregistrées pour
des infractions et là s'il y a des
conventions avec la police ou la
gendarmerie il faut que ce soit la
police et la gendarmerie qui fasse ces
contrôles c'est avec le ministère de
l'Intérieur qu'on a constaté qu'on a
contacté les les mises en demeure que
j'ai adressé vous savez les 38 communes
je les ai pas trouvé toutes seule c'est
parce qu'on a fait on a regardé avec le
ministère de l'Intérieur concrètement
qui est d'accord avec l'analyse de
l'acnil ce que les communes ont le droit
de faire et nonont pas le droit de faire
et ces mis en demeur ont veillé tout
simplement à rappeler ce cadre et par
ailleurs naturellement on accompagne
autant que possible les collectivité
locale on a un Service des délégués à
l'accompagnement on a euh dans notre
cours en ligne un module spécifique pour
les collectivités locales il y a ces
partenariats qu'on a noué avec les trois
grandes associations et une association
qui s'appelle déclic qui regroupe
beaucoup de communes notamment sur
l'aspect informatique on est à la
disposition des communes nous vous
l'avez bien compris dans nos mesures
correctrices si on a 16000 plaintes et
300 contrôles et euh 40 sanctions et 150
mises en demeure par an c'est que
l'essentiel des plaintes euh ou des
enjeux de protection des données on les
traite en conciliation en quelque sorte
donc on accompagnera en tout cas les
collectivités locales sur ce sujet et et
et et je ne doute pas que le cadre
juridique sera clarifié alors monsieur
coulom m'a interrogé sur la régulation
des banques alors comme si les banques
ne faisaient pas l'objet d'une
régulation de l'acnil au même titre
qu'un autre secteur d'activité l' les
banques font tellement l'objet de la
régulation de l'acnil qu'elles sont même
accompagnées de façon spécifique ce qui
est assez rare par l'acnil euh en ayant
créé un club conformité banque il n'en
existe que trois il y a un club
conformité banque un club conformité
pour les assurance et un club conformité
que je viens de lancer il y a quelques
mois pour euh la voiture autonome parce
que naturellement ce sont des enjeu en
matière de protection de vie privée qui
sont considérables donc nous asseyons
autour de la table très régulièrement à
peu près l'ensemble du secteur bancaire
de ses représentants y compris de ses
autorités de la Banque de France
l'Autorité de régulation des banques qui
est plus la PCR d'ailleurs comme vous
savez que
l'acnil pour veiller au respect d'enjeu
de protection des données dans un
secteur très régulé qui par définition
brasse beaucoup de données personnelles
puisque les banques doivent lutter
contre le blanchiment
euh s'intéresser au surendettement donc
il faut concilier les différentes
obligations réglementaires qui pose sur
les banques avec la protection de la vie
privée euh et naturellement tous les
enjeux de tous les principes de la
protection des données droit d'accès
droit d'information et cetera sont des
sujets qui sont non seulement qui font
l'objet d'un accompagnement mais qui
font l'objet d'un contrôle euh depuis 5
ans il y a eu à peu près 60 contrôles
qui ont été faits sur des banques 26
mesures correctrices qui ont ont été
prononcé et dont 15 banques en ligne
avec des problématiques particulières
qui ont été contrôlées et je n'évoque
même pas les différents fichiers que
nous contrôlons notamment le le F CP le
fichier sur les incidents de paiement je
ne parle même pas de l'exercice des
droits indirect puisque nous
recevons plus de 20000 cisines par an
pour des personnes qui veulent savoir si
à juste titre ou pas elles sont
inscrites dans un fichier et 95 % de ces
césines ou si un compte bancaire a été
ouvert euh sans qu'elle le sache et 95 %
de ses saisine concernne FICOBA le
fichier sur les comptes
bancaire alors madame termerer m'avait
posé une autre question excusez-moi sur
le dopage sportif alors l'acnil s est
intéressé dans le cadre de l'examen que
le collège a fait sur la loi sur les
jeux olympiques puisque effectivement
pour la première fois était prévu des
tests génétiques qui sont donc comme
vous l'avez rappelé madame la
députée pas potentiellement
effectivement sur des données
extrêmement
sensibles l'acnil ne s'est pas prononcé
ou n'a pas eu à se prononcer sur le
principe même de ce test dont si j'ai
bien compris qui relève plutôt d'une
obligation lié au euh à
euh à l'autorité de dopage mondial en
quelque sorte mais l'acnil s'est
intéressé au traitement de données qui
peut en résulter tout en insistant
beaucoup et ça a été je crois repris par
le texte sur la nécessité d'informer le
sportif ou l'athlète en tout cas qui va
se soumettre à à ces tests sachant que
ces tests c'est en dernier recours la
limite c'est ENF s'il y a d'autres
méthodes alternatives moins intrusives
elles sont naturellement utilisées donc
laacil s'est intéressé à l'information
des sportifs même si c'est limité parce
que si le sportif ne s'y soumet pas il
ne participe pas à la à la compétition
et elle s'est intéressé aussi au
transfert des données notamment je crois
vers le Canada parce que je crois que
l'autorité mondiale antidopage est au
est au Canada donc en tout cas c'est sur
ces sujetsl que nous avons préconisé un
certain nombre de
garantie sur les faux avis Google c'est
en liaison avec et je vais me dépêcher
monsieur le Président c'est c'est en
liaison avec la DGCCRF avec laquelle
nous avons noué un partenariat et la DG
FIP qui aussi dans le cadre là plus avec
une optique de contrôle fiscal s'est
intéressé euh au faux avis sur Internet
et et à la et à la collecte de ces faux
avis sur internet que nous
interagissons alors plusieurs questions
ont porté sur l'intelligence
artificielle monsieur rond sur Bran sur
l'intelligence artificielle et les
biaiss
euh monsieur Jordan Guiton sur l'A des
fins politiques peut-être euh alors sur
les biais en tout cas c'est une question
tout à fait pertinente que d'avoir en
tête que l'intelligence artificielle
peut produire des biaets ce sont des
méthodes probabilistes il peut y avoir
des erreurs il peut y avoir des biais en
fonction des données qui servent à
l'entraînement effectivement des
systèmes d'intelligence artificielle si
ces données ne sont pas représentatives
de la population par exemple il peut y
avoir en résultat euh des politiques
discriminatoires et c'est bien la raison
pour laquelle l'acnil est très attentive
au fait dans tous les systèmes qu'elle
regarde euh qu'il n'y ait pas de
décision purement automatisé d'ailleurs
qu'il a une intervention humaine que les
données soient pertinentes et on peut
notamment une des actions sur lesquelles
nous travaillons et qui est dans les
fiches que le collège doit adopter
demain euh après consultation publique
on s'intéresse par exemple à la
minimisation des données qui dit
minimisation des données le moins de
données possibles et des données
pertinentes euh peut exclure un certain
nombre de BI je vous prend un exemple on
a interagi avec un laboratoire
pharmaceutique qui veut faire euh de
l'intelligence artificielle pour prédire
ce qui est très bien les les variables
explicatives du cancer de la prostate on
a constaté qu'il y avait des centaines
de millions de dossiers de personnes qui
n'ont pas de cancer de la prostate mais
ça peut se comprendre pour classifier
ceux qui en ont ceux qui n'en ont pas
mais il y avait des femmes par exemple
parmi ces dossiers donc peut-être pas
indispensable voilà donc en tout cas un
des rôles de l'acnil c'est de veiller à
à ce que les systèmes d'intelligence
artificielle puissent autant que
possible préciser les finalités de leur
traitement c'estàdire les usages qui
vont mettre en place nous dire bah c'est
un système de vision par ordinateur pour
détecter des voitures des panneaux de
signalisation et des piétons mais pas
nous dire on entraîne toutes les données
puis on verra à quoi ça sert je vous ai
donné cet exemple sur la minimisation
des données faut pas prendre toutes les
les données il y en a d'autres sur la
conservation des données on conserve pas
les données nécessairement pour la même
durée selon qu'il s'agit d'entraîner les
données qu'il s'agit de détecter des
billets et et dans le le le législateur
nous a autorisé et enfin nous a demandé
même on en était très heureux
d'accompagner par exemple pour les Jeux
Olympiques les fournisseurs d'algorithm
on a accompagné pendant plusieurs mois
une
dizaine d'entreprises
d'industrieles qui vont dont trois ou
quatre d'entre eux vont fournir les
algorithmes qui vont
permettre de qui vont être imposés sur
les caméras qui vont détecter des comp
comportement suspect pour les JO et un
des sujets naturellement qu'on a
particulièrement regardé c'est celui des
biaiss et vous avez évoqué parcours sup
je me permets juste de rappeler que
c'est suite à une mise en demeure de
l'acnil il y a plusieurs années que APB
a été même s'il y avait d'autres raisons
aussi des tirages au sort et cetera
enterré et a été remplacé par parcourss
pour qu'il ait plus de transparence et
pas de décision entièrement automatique
alors monsieur mollac m'a interrogé sur
les rapports avec nos rapports avec les
administrations
euh et à évoqué notamment la
sanction adressée par la commission des
sanctions de l'acni de la formation
restreinte à l'encontre du ministre de
la Fonction publique sur un message
[Musique]
qui avait consisté à utiliser un fichier
de paiement des agents de la fonction
publique pas pour les bonnes pas pour
les bons objectifs euh et c'est vrai que
lacnil a reçu 10 % de ses plaintes sur
ce sujet j'ai saisi la la
commissionction de laacnil j'aurais pu
ne pas la saisir je je l'ai saisi et la
formation restreinte de l'acnil a
effectivement prononcé un rappel à
l'ordre parce que la commission des
sanctions de l'acnil ne peut pas
sanctionner financièrement l'État mais
cela dit la sanction médiatique elle est
me semble-t-il tout à fait
réel également et et par ailleurs en ce
qui
concerne les sanctions dans le secteur
publ j'ai évoqué les drones l'acnil a
émis des a prononcé des sanctions contre
les radars tronçons par exemple en ce
qui concerne le ministère de l'Intérieur
dans la période covid il y a eu des
mises en demeure dont certaines
publiques sur le covid Bery récemment à
propos d'un fichier des douanes qui
fonctionnait sans base légale qui
s'appelle sir donc avec une connotation
maritime et qui concernait des des
informations qui étaient demandées au
bateau et cetera on a demandé il y a eu
une sanction également et un nouveau un
nouveau texte nous a été présenté ça
c'est une façon de répondre aussi au aux
différentes questions qui ont été posées
sur les fichiers c'est que les fichiers
non seulement on les contrôle en rendant
des avis sur des projets de texte qui
nous sont présentés mais on
peut dans le cadre des très nombreux
contrôle qu'on fait notamment dans le
secteur régalien mais y compris dans le
secteur des ministères économique et
cetera
euh demander ou ou ou ou ou ou ou de
fait appeler à des modifications de
texte qui nous sont ensuite présentés
c'est le cas du fichier sirène
euh donc j'ai répondu à Monsieur reberot
et à Madame Ménard sur les drones euh
monsieur
Guitton sur les Jos et les cyberataques
alors bah nous sommes évidemment nous
avons une coordination très forte avec
en tout cas des liens de travail étroit
d'une façon générale avec l'any mais
c'est surtout l'ancy hein qui est
responsable de avec naturellement le CIO
euh des sujets des cyberattaques pendant
les j nous nous nous contentons plus
modestement mais c'est quand même
beaucoup également euh de faire beaucoup
de pédagogie en matière de de
cybersécurité à l'égard de l'ensemble
des citoyens nous avons récemment publié
une recommandation sur les mots de
passes par exemple et je pense que
certains d'entre nous ignoraient avant
cette recommandation qui paraît qu'il
faut pas les changer si fréquemment vous
pouvez aller sur l'acnil le site de
l'acnil qui est consulté près de 12
millions de fois par an ce qui prouve
que quand même les personnes sont
sensibilisées sur nos sujets pour avoir
un générateur de de mot de passe robuste
nous accompagnons beaucoup les
établissements hospitaliers euh sur la
cybersécurité et chaque contrôle que
nous faisons nous contrôlons les aspects
de sécurité parce qu'il y a pas de
protection des données sans de sécurité
des données et la moitié des sanctions
que l'on prononce comporte des
manquements relatifs à la cyber sécurité
et j'ai encore récemment envoyé des
dizaines de mises en demeure à des
administration et à des grandes
entreprises publiques sur des protocoles
de sécurité de cryptage le
https relativement basique donc c'est
des sujets je réponds pas directement
sur les JO mais sur lesquels nous avons
une activité très intense indépendamment
du fait que nous nous sommes très nous
sommes beaucoup intégrés à l'écosystème
cyber nous sommes membres de
cybermalveillance.gouf.fr par exemple
euh il y a des fins politiques bah c'est
tout l'enjeu
euh effectivement je je je je crois que
le jour où on pourra avoir la garantie
d'avoir un marquage en quelqu sorte qui
permet d'indiquer que c'est lia qui a
produit tel ou tel contenu euh sera un
un un un un grand pas euh en avant
monsieur
Solignac m'a interrogé sur ce que
faisait l'acnil par rapport au
[Musique]
au enfin au je sa pas si c'est des
révélations mais en tout cas au aux
informations médiatiques qui ont circulé
sur des traitements de la CAF euh qui
seraient discriminatoires et qui
viserait euh du fait euh de
l'utilisation
d'algorithmes des personnes qui seraient
les plus pauvres et cetera euh alors je
vous donne une information euh nous
contrôlons euh la CAF euh actuellement
et euh les et et plusieurs caisses
d'allocation familiale
euh d'ailleurs par rapport à ce qui est
apparu dans la presse euh
euh ce ne sont pas les mêmes les
algorithmes de la même
époque hein qui euh nous nous contrôlons
des algorithmes beaucoup plus récents
visiblement et et j'espère qu'ils sont
moins en tout cas qui
ne qui qui qui qui ne poseraient pas les
mêmes problèmes que ceux qui ont pu être
relayés donc comme ce contrôle est en
cours je je ne peux pas en dire plus
mais il faut arriver à concilier en tout
cas euh enfin en tout cas sur l'aspect
des discriminations nous nous sommes
rapprochés aussi de la Défenseur des
droits parce que nous nous allons
prolonger cette
action avec elle sur l'aspect
discrimination parce que nous nous
sommes plutôt concentrés sur vraiment
l'aspect protection des données
information des personnes sécurité des
données durée de conservation des
données et cetera mais d'une façon
générale la lutte
contre la la fraude fiscale douanière
sociale et la protection des données
doit être concilié ça fait l'objet d'une
thématique prioritaire de contrôle en
2023 nous avons contrôlé non non
seulement donc la CNAF et descaf mais
aussi la CNAM la Caisse nationale
d'assurance
vieillesse par exemple et l'utilisation
naturellement d'algorithme et quelque
chose que nous regardons plus
particulièrement
euh sur puisque nous parlions
d'algorithmes les caméras algorithmiques
la question de Madame Sandra regol par
rapport à l'utilisation de vidéos
algorithmique par les collectivités
local c'est vrai qu'il y a eu plusieurs
jugements de tribunaux administratifs
récemment je constate que la plupart
quand même ce de Nice de Lille de roubet
par exemple je crois n'ont pas constaté
d'utilisation de reconnaissance faciale
en tout cas dans ces jugements et et
comme vous l'avez soulevé le le Conseil
d'État
euhessentrer mais c'est vraiment si fait
ch madame madame rel c'est moi qui fait
la police de la séance
merci c'est moi qui fait la police
madame voilà donc en tout cas le le
droit en vigueur c'est qu'il y a pas de
possibilité pour les collectivités local
d'utiliser des caméras avec des
algorithmes en temps réel
euh avec des exceptions on a parlé des
lapis par exemple on pourrait parler d'
l'utilisation des algorithmes pour des
fins statistiques certaines des
communes qui ont été l'objet de enfin
qui qui ont fait l'objet de enfin dont
les traitements ont fait l'objet de
recours devant le juge administratif
utilisaient aussi ces traitements à des
fins statistiques ce qui n'est pas
interdit pour
réguler les flux de circulation faire de
l'optimisation énergétique ou autres ou
de l'algorithmie pour les contrôles des
zones de faible émission ou de voies
réservé par par exemple pour les
véhicules avec un certain nombre de
garanties d'ailleurs sur l'acnil c'est
sur sur lesquel l'acnil c'est s'est
prononcé et sur les travaux à venir je
pense que l'acnil va
s'intéresser dans les mois qui viennent
avec son collège notamment à la
question de euh des algorithmes
euh apposés à des caméras et
l'utilisation en temps différés est-ce
qu'on peut utiliser ou pas euh des
algories rythme pour retrouver des
caractéristiques de telle ou telle
personne ou tel ou tel comportement
euh l'acnil veut-elle être le gendarme
de Lia monsieur Rambo
euh en tout cas l'acnil se préoccupe de
traitement d'IA depuis de nombreuses
années maintenant euh et euh je constate
que tant le un rapport du Conseil d'État
de 2022 que un avis de l'ensemble
desciles européennes à la même époque
euh que et et et et d'autres travaux on
ont pointé le fait que laacnil aurait en
tout cas une légitimité à cont tenu de
l'adhérence naturelle qu'il y a entre
les données personnelles et
l'intelligence artificielle euh à avoir
un rôle à jouer de toute façon le
règlement sur l'intelligence
artificielle il vient en complément du
rgpd il ne se substitue pas au RGP et en
tout état de cause la kil aura un rôle
majeur à jouer sur la régulation des
systèmes d'IA et euh il y a ça c'est une
décision qui relèvera des pouvoirs
publics mais il y a en tout cas
euh pour une institution qui a
l'habitude en plus de faire beaucoup de
transversalité et qui est habitué à
interagir avec beaucoup de de
régulateurs et avec beaucoup
d'écosystèmes différents
euh et avec les compétences qui sont les
nôtres je je je pense une
possibilité en tout cas qui devrait être
regardé de près par les pouvoirs public
parce qu'il y a à la fois le rôle de
coordination nationale de de l'IaaS qui
dans le ria s'appelle le single point of
contact mais il y a aussi des rôles de
régulation sectorielle de marché
vraiment de régulation de sécurité des
produits et on peut penser que les
autorités de protection des données
auront un rôle à jouer notamment sur la
surveillance des
algorithmes utilisés notamment pour des
fonctions régaliennes de surveillance
l'immigration ou pour la justice et il y
a un exemple intéressant au Pays-Bas où
où par exemple vient d'être créé au sein
de l'acnil néerlandaise un département
de surveillance et de coordination des
algorithmes séparé du reste de de
l'acnil et qui pourrait être inspirant
monsieur Paris sur le Tage le Tage nous
le contrôlons nous l'avons contrôlé
c'est le traitement des antécédents
judiciaires qui pardon qui je vous
cherchz monsieur le député merci
beaucoup
euh qui effectivement pose des
problématiques de protection de vie
privée importantes puisqu'il s'agit
de de brandir une photographie de
quelqu'un et de
vérifier dans un fichier enfin
d'identifier une personne par de de
cette façon-là donc nous le contrôlons
très régulièrement de la même façon que
nous nous avons contrôlé par exemple
récemment le fichier Acred qui permet de
cribler comme on dit aujourd'hui
euh les bénévoles par exemple et
d'autres personnes qui vont avoir un
rôle à jouer pendant les Jeux Olympiques
pour s'assurer que elle n'est pas un
passé qui serait contre-indiqué par
rapport au rôle qu'elles entendent jouer
dans cette circonstance enfin Madame
Lauro toujours sur les Jeux Olympiques a
attiré mon attention sur les QR codes
alors les QR codes pour beaucoup d'entre
nous
évidemment il peut y avoir une
connotation un peu négative liée à la à
la période sanitaire là sil s'agirait
davantage de QR code liés comme un QR
code que vous présentez pour aller à un
spectacle en quelque sorte d'après ce
que ce que j'ai compris j'ai rencontré
le préfet de police au début du mois de
décembre juste après qu'il est indiqué
effectivement que l'alternative c'était
soit de fermer un certain nombre de
quartiers entiers
ou d'avoir des dérogations pour rentrer
mais en permettant aux personnes
concernées de se connecter à une
plateforme numérique qui délivrerait un
QR code alors outre le fait que l'acnil
est toujours sensible aux questions
d'inclusion et que il faut qu'il puisse
y avoir aussi une alternative à
ce à l'utilisation numérique de ces ces
systèmes
euh j'ai dit au préfet de police que
naturelle ement
nous enfin nous aurions des discussions
avancées très prochainement puisque je
crois que ce système doit être mis en
place en mars ou en avril en tout cas la
plateforme numérique le contrôle des QR
Codes plus tard j'imagine avec le
straitant qui a été
choisi nous serons également le préfet
de police me l'a assuré sollicité pour
rendre un avis sur le texte
qui permet en quel quelque sorte
de en tout cas qui actualisera un arrêté
actuel qui date de 2011 qui avait été
actualisé en 2019 au moment du G7 à
Biaritz et et qui prévoit des filtrages
de des contrôles de sécurité pour les
résidents dans certaines zones et donc
nous nous assurons à à ces deux
occasions à la fois sur la vie que nous
rendrons sur le texte et très
concrètement euh en interagissant avec
le sous-traitant et la préfecture de
police que les principes de sécurité de
ces données de minimisation de ces
données quelles sont les sources de ces
données quelles sont ces données comment
sont-elles sécurisées combien de temps
sont-elles conservés pourquoi qui a
accès nous nous nous assurons que tous
les principes que malheureusement nous
connaissons bien maintenant en termees
de QR code et qui protège la vie privée
soit assuré et tout en cherchant à
concilier encore une fois la la sécurité
euh des Français et la protection de
leur vie privée j'ai le sentiment
monsieur le Président mais peut-être
trompege euh d'avoir essayé de répondre
à l'intégralité des questions voilà
peut-être trop non vous n'êtes jamais
trop complète pour la pour la commission
des lois en revanche vous l'avez été je
crois suffisamment pour que le vote de
nos collègues soit éclairé et que nous
puissions délibérer d'autant que si je
me trompe pas et je l'ai annoncé en
introduction vous êtes attendu au Sénat
pour une audition du même type donc nous
vous libérons nous vous remercions pour
la complétude de vos réponses et puis
nous espérons en tout cas moi je
m'exprime dans ce sens nous espérons
pouvoir vous retrouver bientôt pour les
travaux de la commission des Dris merci
monsieur le Président merci à vous